what's up guys welcome back to my
channel today i decided i want to teach
you how to shave properly so first
things first got to fill up the tub and
you kind of want warm water through that
way it really like makes it easier you
don't have like food from swimming pool
water and if we assume their shape
and then we gotta get our shaving cream
be nice and clean shave every day and
you're always being clean plastic and
eraser and now let's begin um Logan
great so Logan is gonna help me since I
wanted to talk to you guys and give you
like the step-by-step instructions he's
gonna help me do that sick so what we're
gonna do first is Logan put up the leg
[Music]
so we're gonna do usually when I shave I
go to all the way up my thigh that's
where the lighter hairs are but so some
girls don't show you that or guys but um
I do take off the stalk because unless
you don't mind getting shaving cream on
it uh it's just like a decision that you
like you have to make when you shave
your legs
normally I know better than to wear
socks I think at the time I think the
less hair we could shave like if I could
save some ankle hairs I'll be stoked
about it so maybe I'll leave the sock on
okay well compromise say okay so um what
we're gonna do is first oh wait don't
you get it away uh yeah you can't fit a
little water on it oh that's trying to
kill me so it's warm water he's really
gonna just make it nice
the water is not warm see look at all
this hair yes probably was so we got it
nice and wet oh my god yeah if you're
watching this I am so sorry I'm so sorry
next we're gonna put on the shaving
cream you only really need a dollop just
a dollop and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna kind of push it on there no
I'm gonna get back here whoa whoa really
jangling this yeah
chef what my toes or not yeah your toes
all right cool all right so we're gonna
get it all are you okay no so more oh
and you know what's a good thing about
shaving cream is is that really shows
you where the spots you missed so you
really get all the hair so I'm in a tub
full of Logan's features like hair yeah
challenge hi Jetta trust me we're all
prepped up and ready now we're gonna do
our first stroke ah Amanda
gonna take a while I feel like oh no
this just feels wrong no no I've never
done this before oh gosh we here how do
I let you convince me to do this what is
the last time you shaved your legs so
usually like when I shave my legs
it tastes like one stroke and like
you're good it's a big razor for Logan
um he takes about 50 sure this is true
friendship that you trust somebody with
a razor blade against your legs that is
true
I like to consider myself like a man Oh
like aren't I good if I go to gym I got
that moose gomez oh so another tip when
you're shaving is to go upwards on the
leg that way you get like off is that
the shaving cream yeah bye got it but
usually I do it eat pretty uniform when
I shave my own legs but for Logan I
can't really do that I kind of just have
to go hand
Wow you know that's so crazy when you
start to get rid of the hair it starts
to look more like a girl's leg no like I
feel it looks like my leg no a little
stroke a little stroke room
you know what teamwork teamwork makes
the dream work
so now it's better because under a
minute tons of your hair you shaved my
legs
who's winning all right I'll do a stroke
[Music]
don't press too hard
you want to look where you're going this
is how accidents happen oh he's going
all the way oh my gosh
I don't know how why I'm doing this I
got it I got a text from a man that last
night saying let's shave your legs
before I could even respond she said
sleep on it no good thing I don't like
the way it looks
why see and you know shaving your leg is
like a bonding things you know you could
do it and for who for who is it's a
bonding thing for all for us now man
come by thank you it so you saved those
ankle hairs all of my pain and suffering
aside you're very talented
all right let's look at it for a
different angle okay Wow if you have
hairy legs like Logan you might have to
go through a whole pack of razors it's
gonna grow back like more okay are you
breathing do you need CPR all right
rule number two don't wear lip gloss
while you're shaving we're like nine
years old so we're gonna be like well
I'm gonna be fine you're just nine hero
Logan just sitting in the corner yeah
um yeah this is this is not gonna
imagine we're just like to be a girl no
ifs you just everyday I'm cool being a
dude I don't mind it
it is cool man cool stick would you
push speech in your belly then shave
your legs
it's no it's cool why don't you try I
see a couple more hairs on the knee and
remember I told you if you press too
hard you're gonna dick it make it so
just be very careful and don't am i
doing it doesn't hurt that bad but it's
the principle man oh okay
just a little nick full set put pressure
on it and it helps it write it out yeah
it's fine you're okay I'm okay yeah
maybe you should stick to having me
your life yeah yeah yeah any time I want
to shave my legs yeah yeah yeah this is
great
um that is the final product of the leg
right next to each other
oh no yeah I'm disgusting I'm disgusting
lotion on it oh these legs haven't seen
the light of day for a while
understandably because of all the the
hair on them so now you can go lay out
and you'll get a nice tan on your legs
thanks Amanda I really appreciate it
yeah thanks for
doing this with me today it looks like
we have one razor left that will be the
gift to you along as with the sweet
thanks Amanda
all right so let's easy closet or not
good oh I hope I do I hope I do I don't
know if it's I don't working it's a good
sign looks like that was the six best
and so remember that I think it's about
five tips then I could give you guys
thank you guys so much for watching
today make sure you subscribe to my
channel to see all of my videos I post
and also you can click right on here on
this man to check out some of his videos
that's hilarious
hi guys oh my god she's so crew probably
too much nuts it probably should have
got creamy
[Music]